[Music]
i still think drag at this hour should
be absolutely illegal um
in like every state every country every
continent um
but it's cool for the people cornbread
one of my favorites of season 14 of
rupaul's drag race you are incredible
dare i say
you are a fan favorite it does feel
great it seems like that um at this
moment i can't complain about it um you
know i knew what i was gonna get when i
walked in there and it's just my
authentic self and people like to see
that so i'm here for it
[Music]
i was so blown away by your talent show
performance it was incredible someone
else who was also blown away
lizzo how incredible was it to get to be
on that stage and have an icon like
lizzo
appreciate what you do and give you the
words of encouragement i always tell
myself um when i started dragging i
wanted a music career i wanted to be
like the lizzo of the drag world i'm
glad she appreciated it uh i'm still
reaching out to her um no matter how
many times uh she gets a message for me
to put me in the next music video collab
or something
obsessed like highly obsessed another
huge fan of cornbread uh miss ariana
grande who reached out reposted shared
that she could not stop watching you
she's a sweetheart it's still weird um
seeing that pop up on your thing too and
so yeah that was another crazy one too
are we gonna get an ep or full-length
album my mindset so far right now
thinking big ahead um it's like doing
like a visual situation like beyonce did
and just do like us but i won't do it as
big as beyonce obviously but just
hashtag i ain't got that much money but
i definitely want to introduce like a a
good seven song
story
line kind of moment that i think would
be very fun and i probably started off
with the song i did on drag race because
that's like my introduction to
to the world i'm only taking time out of
my time because it's you will love it
i've learned so much from willow that
has enhanced my drag outside of um being
a rupaul's directory um
where
i don't know it's like a a source of
humbleness you you humble yourself when
you meet somebody like willow and you're
like they have something to actually
complain about and they don't complain
about it so why am i complaining about
the bs that i'm moving about are you
okay i'm going through that for a minute
oh baby i'm so
[Music]
i feel sorry
it's a
a good thing for people to see the
different levels of what trans is carrie
was deep into her transition when she
went to the show mine was still a secret
and i wasn't saying anything but it's
also showing the progress of what it is
and not
well knowing that trans is just not one
image of what people think it should be
were you completely
shocked by the response that maddie
kind of got coming into this competition
martin lawrence tyler perry are all
heterosexuals who have been doing it mrs
doubtfire is one of the biggest drag
moments in history
i mean how about there's so many sources
of things that are like monuments to us
so they took this moment and like ran
with it but like you got to commit
maddie for their strength and like not
dealing with it but also us it's
maddie's the sister just like the rest
of the people on the river's drag race
well i'm ready we we in the corner you
know ready to pick up form there's a
huge twist this season with the
chocolate bar what do you think about
this new twist we'll open her candy bar
if it is the gold bar
she'll be safe to slay another day i'm
very grateful for that opportunity to
even be considered to open it up and be
like oh there's a moment it's genius
it's absolutely genius
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos